come sarebbe il mondo
se ogni bambino
ogni professionista ogni scuola ogni
ospedale ogni governo potesse avere
accesso a giuste informazioni e solidi
strumenti per costruire la propria
felicità mi va di fare un esperimento
chiudete gli occhi e immaginate come
sarebbe la vostra vita se voi e tutte le
persone intorno a voi fossero felici
riaprite pure gli occhi dalle
espressioni sul vostro volto posso
immaginare cosa state pensando
alcuni di voi avevano un sorriso che poi
se un po smorzato perché per molti di
noi questa è una visione utopica
siamo infatti abituati a pensare alla
felicità come ad un'emozione molto forte
ma di breve durata o legata a
particolari momenti qualcosa che viene
sempre dopo la realizzazione di
qualcos'altro
e infatti diciamo frasi come sarò felice
quando mi sarò laureata quando sarò
sposata quando avrò fatto carriera avrò
trovato la casa dei miei sogni o
addirittura sarò felice quando andrò in
pensione praticamente mai la gioia è il
mantra della cultura
prima il dovere e poi il piacere con il
quale abbiamo disegnato le nostre vite
educato i nostri bambini organizzato il
mondo del lavoro è costruito le nostre
società e cosa ha prodotto in italia 11
milioni di persone usano psicofarmaci
quanti sono immaginate più o meno tutti
gli abitanti della lombardia in europa
40 milioni di lavoratori soffrono di
stress
una cifra più o meno pari a tutti gli
abitanti della spagna nel mondo un paese
su 5 impegnato a combattere in guerra
sopravvivere alla fame
nelle famiglie all'aumentare dello
stress dei genitori i ragazzi sviluppano
più facilmente dipendenze da alcol e
droghe ma c'è una novità
oggi sappiamo da cosa dipendono questi
risultati drammatici e come possiamo
invertire la rotta
viviamo infatti in un'epoca incredibile
per il progresso della conoscenza la
scienza già svelato finalmente come
funzioniamo e ha dimostrato ad esempio
che la felicità è una competenza e che
ci consente di fiorire come individui e
come sistemi sappiamo ad esempio che i
nostri comportamenti contano e che le
esperienze che facciamo tutti i giorni
modificano costantemente il nostro
cervello se scegliamo di focalizzarci
dunque su esperienze di tipo positivo o
piacevole lo nutriamo di fiducia
autostima senso di sicurezza e
protezione
tutte condizioni che ci permettono di
fioriere ed avere successo facile
non proprio
l'eredità loro lezione ci ha lasciato
infatti in eredità una maggiore
propensione a captare nell'ambiente
esterno pericoli e minacce
la negatività piuttosto che a godere dei
vantaggi della positività perché per
sopravvivere e tramandarci loro geni i
nostri antenati hanno dovuto imparare a
stare alla larga da pericoli e minacce
come predatori la fame e l'aggressione
da parte dei loro simili e anche se oggi
non siamo più cavernicoli alle prese con
animali feroci il nostro cervello fa
scattare lo stesso meccanismo di allerta
ogni volta ad esempio che rimaniamo
impantanati nel traffico
ogni volta che partecipiamo alle
interminabili riunioni di lavoro o
quando qualcuno ci offende e tradisce i
nostri valori
quando non ci sentiamo apprezzati quando
discutiamo con i nostri cari
in queste stesse situazioni oggi come
allora
il cervello fa scattare una reazione
istintiva e primordiale di attacco o
fuga anche detta reazione da stress e
come se non bastasse questa eredità
biologica viviamo costantemente immersi
in un flusso informativo negativo
proveniente da tv social network emilia
vari che continuano ad alimentare nostre
paure più profonde paura della crisi
economica del cambiamento climatico
degli immigrati del terrorismo
internazionale
mancano solo il ritorno della peste
bubbonica e l'invasione delle cavallette
ce le abbiamo tutte e poi ci
sorprendiamo se soffriamo di insonnia o
viviamo costantemente nell'ansia e nella
preoccupazione ed è per questo
sovraccarico negativo biologico e
culturale che facciamo anche più fatica
a superare gli ostacoli della nostra
vita e che diciamo quindi che la
felicità è una competenza che dobbiamo
allenare sapendo che possiamo farlo
perché la scienza ha dimostrato che i
geni non sono il nostro destino e che il
nostro cervello è plastico cioè cambia e
apprende continuamente
quindi se scegliamo di focalizzarlo su
alcune esperienze positive come pensieri
emozioni comportamenti piacevoli creiamo
le condizioni per farlo fioriere abbiamo
la possibilità di creare un contesto che
ri alleni la nostra positività e
interrompa il circolo della negatività e
come si può fare abbiamo tre esercizi
che la scienza ha dimostrato essere
particolarmente efficaci per farci
costruire queste condizioni interiori di
calma lucidità benessere intenzionalità
perché il cervello anche se non è un
muscolo funziona allo stesso modo e
quindi con l'allenamento riusciamo a
ricostruire questi muscoli interiori
come quando andiamo in palestra e quali
sono il primo a smettere di lamentarsi
nell'azienda che ho fondato insieme a
veruska gennari abbiamo coniato l'ashtag
stop alla lamentela perché le ricerche
hanno dimostrato che lamentarsi
disattiva completamente i neuroni
deputati all'area del problem solving
che significa infatti che chi si lamenta
raramente suggerisce una soluzione ma
c'è di più chi si lamentano un solo
disattiva e brucia i neuroni di chi di
se stesso ma anche di quelli di chi lo
ascolta e quindi se non lo vogliamo fare
per preservare la nostra salute
cerebrale
facciamo almeno per responsabilità
sociale
il secondo esercizio che possiamo fare è
ridere di più il sorriso alla
straordinaria capacità di generare nel
nostro corpo un'esplosione di endorfine
i cosiddetti ormoni del benessere
sostanze chimiche che oltre a farci
sentire bene aiuto nel nostro corpo a
distendersi e rilassarsi terzo esercizio
una pausa di due minuti di respirazione
consapevole ogni due ore perché perché
respirare consapevolmente aiuta a
sviluppare la nostra capacità di essere
presenti nel momento presente a far
fluire le emozioni ea riportare il
nostro corpo in una condizione
fisiologica che ci consente di osservare
l'ambiente esterno in maniera più
oggettiva per non rispondere con
reazioni istintive primordiali ma
scegliendo i comportamenti che ci
favoriscono maggiormente viva di provare
allora vi chiedo di sedervi sulla parte
anteriore delle vostre poltrone
lasciando andare a terra tutto ciò che
avete sulle ginocchia
provate a stare seduti con la schiena
dritta
fidatevi di noi non vi succederà niente
chiudete gli occhi per qualche secondo e
iniziate a portare l'attenzione consente
questo momento è in questa stanza
provando a percepire ogni rumore ogni
suono ogni odore intorno a voi sentite
il vostro corpo
il contatto dei piedi con il pavimento
la pancia che si muove ad ogni
ispirazione l'ispirazione distendete i
muscoli del volto e portate l'attenzione
alla punta del vostro naso provando a
percepire l'aria fresca che entra
ad ogni inspirazione e l'aria calda che
esce ad ogni ispirazione
rimanete qualche secondo ad osservare
questo flusso senza forzarlo senza
modificarlo
provate a sentire come via via che
respirate il vostro corpo si rilassa e
la vostra mente si calma
ora fate due bei respiri più lunghi e
profondi consapevoli e quando siete
pronti dolcemente riaprire gli occhi
per il 99 per cento degli ultimi 600
milioni di anni i nostri antenati hanno
vissuto in gruppi dovendosi difendere
gli uni dagli altri per accaparrarsi le
risorse e sopravvivere così facendo
hanno sviluppato un senso di separazione
di noi contro loro queste tendenze sono
stati esasperate fino a portarci alle
tragedie dei conflitti del senso di
competizione di odio di disprezzo
reciproco e separazione a cui assistiamo
tuttora ancora oggi le condizioni di
vita dei nostri antenati oggettivamente
erano dure per la loro sopravvivenza
ma per noi donne e uomini del xx e xxi
secolo
le cose sono decisamente diverse
noi oggi abbiamo potenzialmente tutte le
risorse di conoscenza e materiali per
poter far fiorire ogni individuo e ogni
sistema ma per gare la propensione alla
negatività dobbiamo sforzarci tutti di
più di lavorare sulla nostra
trasformazione personale per ricostruire
i nostri muscoli interiori di calma di
resilienza di forza di creatività di
lucidità e possiamo farlo
iniziando a lamentarci di meno sorride
devi più e respirare più consapevolmente
ricordate quale sensazione provano il
vostro corpo e la vostra mente quando
riposano in uno stato di calma e cosa
significherebbe interagire con altri che
provano le stesse sensazioni come
cambierebbe la vostra vita come
cambierebbero le relazioni di lavoro o i
rapporti tra paesi
se tutti agissero a partire da questa
condizione fisiologica di felicità
perché la felicità e la nostra casa
originaria è il luogo dove abitano la
nostra creatività
la nostra calma la nostra lucidità la
nostra intenzionalità e da cui dipendono
quindi il nostro successo è la pace e
dunque per il nostro benessere di tutti
quelli che verranno
dopo di noi che ci auguriamo di poter
ritornare presso tutti in questa casa
[Applauso]